francia conoció el informe más
espeluznante
216 mil niños abusados por alrededor de
tres mil doscientos sacerdotes cifra que
asciende a 330 mil si se tiene en cuenta
cualquier persona vinculada a la iglesia
es el balance de los últimos 70 años
revelado en un informe de 2500 páginas
elaborado durante dos años y medio por
una comisión independiente su presidente
jean max sobre denunció la indiferencia
de la iglesia durante años
o fundó una indiferencia profunda una
indiferencia total e incluso una
indiferencia cruel durante años a las
víctimas ni se las cree dice las escucha
indiferencia a que el líder de los
obispos franceses trató de reconducir en
el mismo acto de publicación del informe
six inbound les expreso mi vergüenza mi
horror mi determinación a actuar por
ellos abigail
la comisión a remitida a la fiscalía 22
presuntos delitos que aún pueden
perseguirse y piden que se repare e
indemnizar a las víctimas éstas siguen
pidiendo justicia usted lo que deben
comprender es que son una vergüenza para
nuestra humanidad
ustedes
deben de pagar tú por todos tú
estos crímenes
la comisión fue establecida por obispos
católicos en 2018 aunque trabajó de
forma independiente su objetivo ha sido
esclarecer la verdad y restaurar la
confianza pública esto se produce un año
después de la condena a cinco años de
cárcel al sacerdote bernat reinado que
reconoció haber abusado a más de 75
niños durante décadas